[Musica]
le cose semplici non mi sono mai
piaciute
ricordatevi questa frase questa frase ha
fatto da filo conduttore per diversi
anni della mia vita
e in effetti fin da ragazzina compresi
quanto risolvere grossi problemi mi
avesse dato l'opportunità di crescere e
di comprendere che la vita non è ciò che
ci accade ma è come reagiamo a ciò che
ci accade come disse albert einstein a
18 anni il mio primo cancro a 38 il
secondo nel frattempo diversi
cambiamenti e relazionali e lavorativi
sono passata da un lavoro sedentario in
ufficio ad un viaggiare quotidianamente
lungo e largo per la romagna
solo dopo essermi fin troppo complicata
la vita mi sono resa conto che tendiamo
a replicare copioni a reiterare pensieri
parole comportamenti che inevitabilmente
danno sempre gli stessi risultati così a
40 anni decisi di prendere un tempo per
me un momento dove fare chiarezza
un momento per rigenerarmi per
comprendere come reagire in maniera
strategica ed efficace e riprendere le
redini della mia vita nelle mani
vi siete mai sentiti in difficoltà
vi siete mai sentiti sopraffatti dalla
confusione che ne deriva perché vedete
tutti voi io
tendiamo a fare ciò che già conosciamo
ma che in un momento in un contesto
diverso non è detto che funzioni
un po come un nuotatore inesperto che
con la paura di affogare non fa altro
che sbracciarsi dimenarsi e più di
sbracci in realtà cosa fai che fughi
mentre se ti acqui e t and t calmi un
attimo capisci che galleggi da solo e
quindi è stato questo agire in maniera
controintuitiva questo andare
controverso che in realtà mi ha risolto
tutta la matassa delle difficoltà che mi
ero creata
nasce così il mio progetto di cancer
coaching
il mio obiettivo era quello di far
risparmiare tempo di sofferenza le
persone dando dandogli degli strumenti
pratici affinché uscissero dalla paura
dal dubbio di non farcela
erano anni che mi fermavo 360 gradi
perché avere un coach a fianco significa
accelerare il processo significa
acquisire strumenti e ottimizzare le
percentuali di soluzione e quindi mi
metto a fianco delle persone coinvolte
direttamente indirettamente con la
malattia aiutando oltre 200 casi mi sono
anche resa conto che la difficoltà sotto
forma di sintomo è quella che poi con il
tempo si trasforma in problema e quindi
malattia ed è da qui che ho preso spunto
per poi creare il mio metodo di gestione
della difficoltà in modo che potesse
abbracciare anche proprio tutte le
esigenze più disparate
alzi la mano chi non ha mai avuto una
difficoltà non va azzardate non va
salvate
perché ancora piccolo
ancora non è iniziato le elementari
forse
tutti siamo con le mani abbassate tutti
siano con le mani abbassate perché tutti
abbiamo delle difficoltà
io credo non esista persona sulla faccia
della terra che non abbia mai avuto una
difficoltà e credo anche che ognuno di
noi in realtà abbia fatto il meglio
quegli strumenti che aveva ma vedete è
proprio questione di acquisire strumenti
nuovi affrontare è diverso che gestire
affrontare in qualche maniera è un
andare in maniera inconsapevole maniera
automatica mentre gestire significa
valutare vantaggi e svantaggi risorse
pratiche non ricercare le possibili
soluzioni e creare anche un piano
dettagliato di azione quindi una
sequenza di passaggi che mi porta la
soluzione del problema
ed eccomi quindi a spiegarvi il mio
metodo di difficoltà management e quindi
gestione della difficoltà è un metodo è
un metodo testato strutturato ma non
credete non sia flessibile perché in
realtà l'ho creato affinché si affianchi
alla persona in maniera personalizzata e
fatto di quattro passaggi 1 identifica
la difficoltà 2 comprende la dinamica 3
ricerca le possibili soluzioni
quattro sceglie la soluzione migliore
nel primo passaggio con domande ed
esercizi pratici si comprende quale ed
interpretazione che la persona sta dando
alla difficoltà e per quali motivi
rischia di entrare in crisi già con
questo solo passaggio la persona
acquisisce
una consapevolezza nuova e quindi anche
una visione molto più chiara e
dettagliata nel secondo passaggio invece
ci sono delle domande e degli strumenti
per comprendere la dinamica che sta al
di sopra della difficoltà in quali
contesti si replica o si è replicata
anche per conoscere i punti di forza su
cui fare leva per poi passare al terzo
passa passaggio la romagna si sente per
passare al terzo passaggio dove si vanno
a ricercare le possibili soluzioni e
quindi si disegnano diverse strade dove
la persona sostanzialmente incomincia a
vedere una panoramica diversa e quindi
anche creare uno scenario al di là della
difficoltà per poi arrivare al quarto
passaggio dove si sceglie la soluzione
migliore ed efficace e quindi è un
azione pratica che la persona può fare
fin da subito e può mettere in atto
affinché cambi il suo schema di reazione
vedete room per gli schemi è possibile
ma in un processo di cambiamento bisogna
farlo a piccoli passi e un passo alla
volta perché sennò si rischia di venire
schiacciati dalla situazione cambiare
significa aggiungere quindi aggiungere
un nuovo schema di reazione a quello già
preesistente in modo che mi possa
tornare utile anche per le prossime
volte vi racconterò anche due casi ma
prima proviamo a riepilogare il metodo
quindi metti che ad essa comprende la
dinamica ricerca le possibili soluzioni
scegli le soluzioni migliori adesso che
conosciamo i passaggi vi racconto la
storia di chiara
la storia di chiara è una storia di
cancro ma non sono qui per affliggervi e
quindi tranquilli vi racconto la storia
in realtà di una figlia che affianca la
madre che si ammala di cancro all'età di
57 anni il bisogno dichiara è un forte
bisogno di riconoscimento
ognuno di noi è fatto di bisogni quindi
bisogno di riconoscimento il bisogno di
certezza di incertezza e anche di legame
appartenenza
questi bisogni intrinsechi che sono
dentro di noi in maniera inconsapevole
andiamo a soddisfare quindi vediamo come
il bisogno di riconoscimento in chiara e
come la dinamica si è presentata chiara
si dedica completamente alla madre
nonostante senta un senso di
frustrazione ed impotenza che molto
spesso affligge chi sta vicino ad un
malato nel seguire la madre in realtà
sta mettendo a dura prova le altre
relazioni e anche tutto il contesto
lavorativo la sua produttività è ridotta
ai minimi termini dopo un'analisi e dopo
la comprensione della dinamica è stato
chiaro per lei quanto il suo bisogno di
riconoscimento e quindi fare tutto per
gli altri non sentirsi quasi mai
all'altezza
in realtà l'avesse ancorata alla paura
di perdere il controllo
quindi ho lavorato con lei nella cup
nella necessità di lasciar andare nel
mollare il peso delle responsabilità su
quali erano i vantaggi e gli svantaggi
di fare troppo per la madre troppo per
gli altri affinché potesse ricostruire
una forza e una determinazione e
un'energia nuova
anche per seguire la madre in una
maniera completamente diversa in una
maniera
attiva sia per il suo bene quello degli
altri nessuno può dare ciò che non ha ok
la storia di beatrice invece beatrice
una donna manager che lavora per un
importante azienda nel settore
immobiliare e ci lavora da oltre 25 anni
invece il bisogno di beatrice è un
bisogno di certezza la vita non ha dato
l'opportunità a beatrice di dare la vita
un figlio e quindi beatrice per
compensazione ha dato la vita la sua
carriera per il suo bisogno di certezza
e quindi anche il crearsi un porto
sicuro e sentirsi riconosciuta ha
dedicato tutto il tempo al suo lavoro
tralasciando anche qua relazioni le
passioni che in realtà ha sempre avuto a
cuore e quindi si ritrova 50 anni che è
stanca priva di stimoli e anche con il
dubbio che sì forse per persa qualcosa
vedete tutti cerchiamo di mantenere che
sia una casa un lavoro una relazione con
la paura di perdere
molto spesso ci perdiamo l'opportunità
di guadagnare e quindi emozioni tempo
esperienze ci si perde un po il senso
della vita diciamoci la verità e quindi
con beatrice con il metodo ho cercato di
fare chiarezza
lei ha compreso quanto il tempo abbia un
valore inestimabile ma esauribile è
quindi forte di questa nuova
consapevolezza e di tutto ciò che gli
aveva creato rimanere ancorata al
bisogno di certezza acquistato una nuova
forza per innanzitutto delegare
tutto ciò a livello lavorativo dove lei
poteva essere sostituibile
ma al tempo stesso anche di iniziare a
creare nella sua routine giornaliera
degli spazi per lei e quindi dedicarsi
alle sue passioni
vi ricordate quando vi dicevo che le
cose semplici non mi sono mai piaciute
benissimo driver vedo che state attenti
ecco oggi dopo mille peripezie mie e
delle persone che ho seguito posso dirvi
con certezza che in realtà la vita è
molto semplice ma noi insistiamo per
renderla complicata e quindi come disse
la wto
inizia le cose difficili quando sono
facili e fai le grandi cose quando sono
piccole un viaggio di mille miglia
inizia sempre con il primo passo quindi
gestisci e previene anziché curare
[Musica]